thanksgiving is a week from today local
non-profits are asking for your help as
the holidays roll in they're asking for
the community really step up and donate
yeah christian casa spoke to a few local
groups about what they need for to keep
families a little jolly this season
so that's one need that we have this
holiday season is we'd love to have some
more volunteers it's the most happiest
and busiest time of the year according
to captain anthony barnes with the
salvation army as they prepare to keep
local families in need smiling our bell
ringers are starting to go out to the
stores
we have lots of volunteers and a few
employees that are going to help us with
that effort
and this year we're going to need some
more bell ringers as traditional
services like rental and utility
assistance continue to roll out this
local non-profit is looking to step up
their efforts during the holidays we
want to make sure that we have enough
especially for that 10 to 12
year range we notice that people love to
buy toys for the cute little ones
but somewhere along the line that 10 to
12 year old age kind of gets left out
others like the las vegas rescue mission
tell us there is a need to fill their
supply containers catholic charities
turning to social media days before
thanksgiving to help adequately serve
thousands of families
when in doubt a money donation can be
the best option this holiday the great
thing about the money donations is that
allows us to address whatever the
specific need is christian casa is live
local now